[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
uh speaking of stars it was pretty
exciting while
i was doing the show and i'm keeping an
eye on what was going on with team usa
the soccer team facing the netherlands
and then it was a penalty shootout and
then all of a sudden it dawns on me
again that alyssa nair the goalkeeper is
somebody i've known i think she's been
like 10 or 11 years of age
she's there stopping these penalty kicks
and i'm acting like she's my daughter
i'm nervous and uh listen there the star
of
team usa joining us from the uh team bus
how do you feel alyssa
hey doing good thanks for having me i
feel great uh just happy to get the win
um moving on to the semifinals a big one
for us oh no no no
that's you're giving me that this stock
you know
come on you you got to be you got to be
excited
i am i'm very excited um this is this is
a good one for us um we needed it
um and yeah i've been
very very excited proud of the team part
of the group um you know came into this
just wanting to
do what i could to help this team win
gold medal and proud of the performance
i was able to put in tonight and help us
get one step closer to that
how nervous were you uh probably not as
much as my parents but
kind of checked in with them afterwards
but i think they're still standing
i i can't imagine the family
yeah i was nervous watching you but what
how much scouting reports do you have
on penalty kicks with tendencies of
players
uh you know it's kind of a mix
everyone's kind of got their own
um you know routines or you know methods
of how
to go about shootouts and different
things and i think the biggest thing is
just trying to
in a moment stay um you know it's
focused and
you know as clear-headed as you can in
that moment and
uh let all your things and training kind
of take over and
um you just kind of hope for the best
from there you're on the team bus right
now
i am okay are you are you being quiet on
purpose because you don't want to
be the star here and like if it was
repino we would be able she'd be yelling
and screaming
yeah you know there's two different
kinds of people in this world
[Laughter]
you look angry is that is that on
purpose when when you're in goal
uh i don't think it's meant to come off
as anger but more of a
focus kind of thing just kind of staying
in the zone i guess that's my zone face
are you uh is it a scowl like are you
trying to present something
to uh the opposition uh
i'm really not i think that's just kind
of what what my face looks like
what was the celebration was there a
celebration after the win
uh yeah i mean it's just a lot of um you
know a lot of hugs
a lot of you know everyone's excited
everyone's
uh you know it's a big one for us um you
know it's gonna come quick we've got
another now semi-finals in two days i
think so
we'll be able to enjoy it tonight be
excited and tomorrow we're gonna have
switch gears pretty quickly
yeah you have canada on monday what do
you know about canada
we played them a few times so um it's
always a hard-fought battle with them um
you know regional opponent play them
often
very familiar with each other um and
it's always
always a battle um so we're we're gonna
have to bring
our a game to that and hopefully this
this game
we can kind of ride this high into that
game and get a good result
my best to your parents and uh
congratulations so far
and how about we don't have it go to uh
penalty kicks next time melissa
yes yes i'm sure my my parents would
appreciate that one
uh congrats and uh good luck all right
that's uh listen there she's the uh
goalkeeper for team usa